doesn't mean the founders thought they  had arrived at the final form of  government in every particular what it  meant was just government in its very  essence the basic things that it aims at  remains the same however the securing of  our natural rights to life to liberty to  the pursuit of happiness as the  Declaration of Independence explains  they thought that men as individuals  possessed rights by nature rights that  any just government was bound to uphold  rights which stood as inherent limits on  the authority of government lying in the  sand that could not be crossed right the  regulatory aims of the progressive  policy agenda the redistributive aims of  the progressive policy agenda about  which they were very open just look at  the progressive party platform for  instance in 1912 just one example those  aims certainly were on a collision  course with the political ideas of the  founding and the progresses are very  open about that  Oh  you